Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and welcome to Hello Neighbor LIVE. (x2)
You may be wondering why I'm repeating that over and over again, but because it's a livestream I never know when it's gonna start.
So, hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Hello Neighbor LIVE. So...
You guys are all here and the stream is just about to start to everybody in the world out there.
Maybe, but we'll see about that. So...
Hello, hi, how's it going, welcome to the stream everybody.
Welcome, welcome. Is it time yet?
Is it happening?
Is it? No?
Maybe? Just maybe?
A little bit there.
Oh no, it's not there yet.
Why is it not there?
Hello?
Helloo?
Uh oh, spaghetti-o
Can anyb-can you guys hear me?
Can you guys see me? Hello?
Cause I can't see myself.
For some reason the stream is not working.
Why is it not working?
Oh yeah you-you see it oh okay, hi guys, how's it going there?
Welcome to Hello Neighbor LIVE, and we are going to get started in just a little bit.
It's obviously early, but I always like starting these livestreams a bit earlier than usual.
Now you may be noticing that I'm using my seductive soft speaking voice, um,
because like I said in Bendy, I have laryngitis, which is super weird because normally
when I'm talking, like I go about my every day it's like a minor sore throat but nothing bad,
but as soon as I start recording and put any strain on my voice,
my voice just disappears after one video so I'm trying to keep it a little bit softer
and more smooth for you guys and for me, and my own sake, so-
This is going to a super chill Hello Neighbor experience,
uh, and as you know about Hello Neighbor it does not usually end up being very chill for anybody,
let alone you or me, so,
Hello.
How are you guys doing-I can see you in chat out there so let me know how it be.
Hi Bryan Haney, thank you so much.
Yeah? Oh, I know a lot of you guys are in school,
but don't worry about it,
school will be out soon and you'll realize how unimportant school is,
that's Markiplier wants to start out this livestream.
I wanna tell you all, uh,
that you should abandon school as soon as possible.
It is no good.
Just, look at your primo example here
I dropped out of college, so,
what good is education?
That's a goddamn lie.
Stay in school, you-stay in school.
Do not abandon it
Once you get to college, then you can decide what you wanna do with your life,
but for that primary education,
that's your baseline level of intelligence that you need
for-to keep up with the rest of the world
so just-keep on that school.
Once you get to college, do whatever you want,
but, as far as normal school go, stays in there.
Unless, unless you're cool.
Unless you're really cool
and you wanna be, like, super cool, then maybe.
But only then.
And I don't even know if you guys are cool enough, so,
yeah ._.
Just follow my lead,
on all of that
yeah ._. ._. ._. ._.
School is a bit important.
Wooh, hello, sorry.
School's important.
Says who?
No,
eh-it-it's not so much that school is important,
school is important for the general public
but, for the-on the individual level,
school may not seem important,
but learning, is important.
Now I sound like a PSA here,
but this is what I'm gonna say about that; learning, is essential.
Learning is something that you're gonna do for the rest of your goddamn life,
so you better learn how to do it.
School is set up to teach you,
not things,
but it's set up to teach you how to learn.
Or it should be set up to teach you how to learn.
In-in school it's set up to teach you things,
but really, the core concepts is
how to teach yourself, to learn.
Because once you learn that skill,
Uh-literally it may seem like counterintuitive
but once you learn how to teach yourself how to learn,
that's when you're able to open up the doors for whatever you want to do in the future
because if you can teach yourself something
because knowledge is out there
each of us have, a goddamn phone
with the entire library of human knowledge in palm of our hand.
Once you teach yourself, how to get information from there into your brain,
like, that's when the world opens up to you.
So, anyway...
but like I said, yeah,
abandon school.
Uh, Michael Nixon says,
'Mark I love your videos, especially during the hard times in my life.
You're always there, thank you for that.'
And thank you for being here.
The other jayzee says
'that smooooth voice makes me feel like I'm listening to a smooooth  jazz station.'
Well,
I hope to make it as jazzy as possible
I wish I had some, jazz music to play here
maybe I could pull up a playlist of, uh,
uh, royalty free jazz music (his voice is so seducing).
Hmm,
lemme get something, real jazzy here.
How about this? Is this gonna be good?
Ooh.
That's jazzy.
That's nice (voice so seductive it gave me an orgasm).
How's that everybody? Does that come through okay?
I have no idea how this sounds to you guys
but I assume it sounds, beautiful (yes it does Mark).
A little bit of, pre, sub
Wh-presub, presubscribe,
before you-before you subscribe, which you obviously gonna do
and everyone should do, so go out and tell everybody
subsc-cribe.
Tell me that you told them to subscribe.
And then I will, congratulate you for being awesome
and, telling them to subscribe to me.
Go do that, right now.
No, don't do that.
Listen to this smoothness
Mmm. That's good.
Ah that's good.
So, flaming serpent says, 'love and respect from Russia,
thank you for being here.'
Thank you everybody out in Russia.
I know I actually have a large fanbase in Russia.
I am actually aware of that.
Uh, so when I do a tour or something
I do wanna go to Russia someday
and I wanna go to Russia someday,
just because,
I-I'm very interested in that country.
Samford says, 'love you, thank you.'
Uh, Shay's Cosplay says,
'trying to get 10K subs, help a girl out.'
Why not?
Why not? There you go. There's a little shoutout.
[Insert name here] thank you.
Uh, SK Pacman says 'thanks for being an inspiration,
keep doing what you do.
You inspired me to make my own gaming channel.'
Yeah.
That's good.
How's the audio?
The audio's good? I don't have no idea.
It might be bad.
But I'm gonna assume it's good.
Just a little,
a little, a little softer.
A little softer.
Alright.
Brock Donson (or whatever it is) 'hey Mark I just want a shoutout that's all.'
Well, there you go.
Uh, Vape Brother,
'uh-er-what was the game you played that we voted on mods?
Like we gave you one foot and all that.'
That was Killing Room
and, er, not to be confused with Killing Floor.
Killing Room was one where you guys were able to vote
and I have not-I-I don't know if I played that on a livestream setting yet
but I will, soon.
See, *laugh* [Insert name here] says 'Mark, go back to cla-college.'
I don't think so, or maybe someday.
Uh, [Insert name here part 2] says 'you are awesome I always love your videos and your deep, soothing voice.'
There's no music?
How can you not hear music?
What?
Is that better?
Why is it so-?
Wait.
Can you not hear this?
Did I sc-? Oooooohh....
Yeah, that-that-that'd probably be the problem.
Oops!
*end of smooth jazz number plays*
There we go...
right at the end of the jazz song
you guys weren't able to hear that *laugh*
Just because it's a smooth, smooth session
does not mean that it's in any way professional, so,
how about that?
Probably a little loud (x2).
Probably just a little loud, I'm gonna bring that down just a bit.
There we go.
How's that?
Is that good?
That's probably good.
Okay.
Alright.
Errr....let's see where did I leave off?
[Insert name here part 3] says 'oh my god I made to another livestream.
Damn it it's been a while since Hello Neighbor, Mark
Keep up the inspiring work.
Lots of love from Australia.'
Thank you Australia.
This next one goes out to you.
Just pretend that I'm playing.
Just ma-imagine in the-in th-in the movies and your mind,
that I'm playing these soothing jazz songs that I really hope you can hear,
and I have no idea if they're actually playing to you.
But if they are,
then great,
and I'm happy for you.
Mmmmmmmmm
that's good stuff.
Hi guys.
Welcome everybody that joins-who's looking in the normal 8AM time slot
I know there's a lot of you that have alarms set for, uh, 8 and noon
and I really appreciate you guys being here so
if you're here, during that time, for that reason,
thanks for being here.
Oh yeah,
that's good stuff.
Mmmmm, jazzy.
Let's see.
Tim Hicks says 'hi, Mark, love your voice and vids
I left a like, shoutout, please.'
Oh,
of course.
Anybody that leaves a like and gets us closer to
waboom
one million li-subscrib-
one million subscribers
that's all I really want.
If I could actually go down in subs, that'd be great.
Yeah,
or up.
Either way.
Maybe stay even,
maybe get an even ratio of subs to unsubs.
I have no idea.
Do whatever you want, actually.
I don't-I don't know honestly *laugh*
I don't honestly put a lot of value in that,
but, thank you all so much for being here.
And I'm pretty sure
I'm almost 100% sure here's, a little piercing behind the veil
of, uh,
of YouTube um,
I'm positive
the like button is placebo,
100%,
and I-I know that's a revelation to you in all the other videos
that people would have done about how the like button means absolutely dick.
But you can press it, all you want.
All you want, and I am-I am-I am almost 100% positive that YouTube does not care,
Because
there's been no effect ever seen from, like, getting likes,
telling people to like, like
uh, bring the likes, not that I'm knocking the practice, I-I don't care
it's-it's a nice feedback, for me.
That's what I think it is.
It's feedback for me, the creator.
To look at that and be like
ooh, a lot of people like that,
ooh, I should do more of that,
you know what I mean?
That's what I take it as,
so, so when you guys like something,
I'm, in my mind, I'm like ah man
you guys, you guys really, fricking like that
like, and-and I know, like
the most liked things are like the Don't Laugh challenges and stuff like that
and some particular videos here and there
so I'm like I was-I was in mindful of that
and I look out for that.
And it's always-it's always interesting to see
so that's what I think the like button is.
It's-it's not so much, an algorithmic thing
which I don't think it ever was,
like I-I don't think it ever-
mmm-maybe in the the past when they had, like, like lists or something but,
I think it was more...
it-it's more just uh, like an indication for the creator,
just to be like hey,
I'm doing good, or
if there's dislikes it's like
ooh, shouldn't do that again I'm not gonna do that, yet
it-it's-it's nothing more than uh,
nothing more than just a little,
a little added buffer, you know,
for interactivity and seeing what you guys, appreciate and don't.
Oh yeah,
uh, oh yeah, that's right
umm,
someone said, [Insert name here part 4] said 'OneShot isn't over,
uh, you have to delete the game files and start again.'
I'm aware of that,
there was a recent update, to the game
uhhhh.....
the solstice update
so, I-I do plan on going through it there again
and, in one more big episode because I heard it's long
so I'm gonna have to do that, uh, in one big.
Uh, Destiny Brunelle said 'I just wanted to say thank you for filling my days with laughter and just general happiness,
You've helped me to be a better person through the years
for-of watching you and I'm glad I found your channel.'
Thank you so much for being here.
Gabrielle Hess says
'I just want to say you inspire me to be a better person and I love the compassion you give
to every individual you meet.'
Thank you very much.
And I appreciate everybody that's, saying they enjoy
the, uh, the soothing nature
of the stream, I know, I know.
Uh, lemme speed through a few more of these, I'm gonna get in back-get into actual Hello Neighbor.
Nicolette Bapp (sorry if I spelled it wrong) says 'hey, Mark, just wanted to pop in before work and say thank you for existing,
you've been making my two weeks of being super sick much more enjoyable.'
Well I hope you feel better very soon.
Uh, Jake in Japan
says 'I love what you do, man, I never get to see you live and I'm super happy that you decided to stream at this time.
You keep doing-you man, the world is a better place with you in it.
Much love from Japan.'
I think the world is a better place for you being in it.
Umm,
A Simple [incoherent]
Deeeath says
'Hey, Mark, I started watching your videos a few months ago,
and it made me wanna make my own gaming channel,' so,
I do wish you luck out there.
Uh, Dylan Hollerfield (or something, I'm terrible at names) says 'keep up the good work Mark,'
uh, Jasmine Shoals (or something) says
'you've developed so much through your channel and I love these livestreams
it feels oddly personal which I really like, thank you Mark.'
Well,
that's what I've always wanted it to be.
it-it-I like-I like, like, the livestream aspect of it
and, and the reason I'm doing a livestream at 8
is because,
my voice just wasn't up to making a, uh, normal, video recording for this time slot so,
I'm just doing one of these
and I'll get into the game very quickly.
Uh, Roadshack says, uh,
'yo Mark, got my daughter to watch your FNAF series,
it's her birthday Monday,
could I get a happy breeday to Alice,' so,
Happy birthday, Alice.
Alright, and Bethany Harpall (or something) says 'hey, Mark,
my kids get super excited anytime you're onscreen
and will try to talk to you,
so I was wondering if you could say hi Tory.'
Hello Tory, hi, how you doing?
Uh, Christophen Whoole (sorry if I messed it up) says 'keep up the good work,
you inspired me to start my own gaming channel.'
Chri-Christophen Whoole (again, sorry if I messed it up).
Alright enough of the shoutouts,
you guys are obviously just pandering, I see how it is.
Let's see,
Hero Brian says 'my name is Dan,
I just want to say thank you,
for making me feel better over the last few days.
Lol, just threw up during the act.'
Well,
during the ACT I'm assuming that is
so, congratulations on ,er,
the ACT and I hope that didn't impede your progress for that.
Uh, Neighbor Gabe (if I'm saying these wrong, I'm so sorry) says 'thank you.'
Stanley Burge says 'if you're ever dating, I'll buy you some dank chickie nuggies.'
I don't know *laugh* I didn't know date nights,
that's in Ohio.
Er, refer to them as such.
Er, Kinetic Shadow says 'thank you so much,
love your videos, you saved me in my darkest times.'
KPopAndK says
'I'm heading to college class now, if you're still streaming in four hours, I'll definitely watch.'
No, this is gonna be a short stream, just an hour,
and I'm gonna get to the game in just a short moment here.
Umm,
Sophie Northcott said 'hey Mark,
love you lots.
Uh....
I love the livestreams; it feels very personal and like we're just chilling with you as a friend.'
I think the smooth jazz (of course) adds to that and,
and I-I'm not sure, I'm not sure,
*laugh* I'm not sure I would command my close friends to go out and,
tell people to subscribe to me.
In fact actually...
that's a goddamn lie
because that's part of- (laugh) that's one of the things I did when I was starting out as a YouTuber, uh,
not that I don't appreciate you guys going  out and doing that
but when I was first starting as a YouTuber,
I would, er,
I-I would literally, just, hammer my friends with messages and be like
I started a YouTube channel,
can you-can you subscribe to me? Wurrrr!
And then I-I-my friend Michelle was the first person that ever subscribed to me,
uh, and-and I always appreciate that.
It-it was just hilarious because
none of them watched, like obviously.
Actually, a few of them do-did watch
and a few of them, still do occasionally
like, er, my friend Jesse (or Jessie) who flew out here and visited me
And then, uh, my friend Matt Howes (sorry if I got this wrong)
Who just had a baby!
Uh, congratulations, Matt, on the baby.
Uh, you know, they watch,
And I'm sure, like, a few of them-
My other friends have seen videos here and there
And I'm always, like, a little embarrassed, but, you know,
Occasionally, I'll get a few shoutouts.
Oh, also! Craziest thing happened.
Uh, my buddy Sam Spencer from high school, um..
he-he-he works in, uh, I think DPReview.com, I'm pretty sure he does?
And I know this - I didn't know this before, but I know this now
because I was looking on Amazon at different cameras
and I was watching the video, like, previews of the cameras
and it was just, like, "Hi, I'm Sam," and I'm like *breathes in deeply* *scoffs incoherently*
I-it's-it's Sam! It's Sam! Oh my God, it's Sam!
And I'm just like, "Oh, holy shit, there you are, man! Haven't seen you in ages."
Anyway, this is all fluff, ha-it-like, just, everyone say hi to Sam for me.
Everyone tell Sam to subscribe *starts laughing* if he's not subscribed.
Everyone call up a friend right now, text all your family and friend members, tell them to subscribe to Markiplier.
If you do, I'll give you a personal handshake when I see you next.
It's gonna be the best handshake that you'll ever see in your life.
Uh, just, like, per-like, if you see me, just be like, "Hey, told all my family and friends to subscribe.
Gimme that handshake." And I'll be like, "You've-" *weird burp hiccup thing* "You've earned this."
And then I'll choke because I'm so sentimental about it.
Anyway, so now I'm gonna get into the game here.
Let's turn off this smooth jazz because I don't think smooth jazz is approrpiate for...
*breathes* uh, Hello Neighbor material.
Now, I'm gonna need your guys' input if this is actually terrible or not
because I have no idea if this is, uh...a good volume or not.
And I'm-I'm sure you won't know until I actually get in there, so,
This is a completely new session.
Obviously, with Hello Neighbor, there is no saving, um...
So I've just gotten it here, so what I need to do is I need to get in, do all the things that I haven't-
That I have already done..
And if I can find a way to trap the neighbor,
Do I have a flashlight in my bedroom?
No, I don't think I do.
*bass begins playing*
Wha-I'm in MY house.
I'm in, MY house.
*bass continues*
I'm in MY house.
Why?
Alright, fine then.
*bass stops*
Apparently, my house is haunted...
by just a bass--a bass player, just--
*imitates background bass*
--like I've got a bass play--
is it Racist Bassist?
Is that Racist Bassist?
Oh jeez...
What is--why?
*bass stops*
Okay.
*bass continues*
Did he get stuck or something?
Oh. Where is he?
*bass stope*
...I dunno--*inturrupted by bass*
What in the...?
This game is so broken.
This game is SO broken, it sounds like he might be stuck somewhere.
So I'm gonna assume that's true.
...And not wait for any sort of verification.
Alright.
So what we need to do--
Oh, *gasp*
He's stuuuuuuuuuuck??
*inhuman gasping noises*
*singing* We've got a golden tiiiicket~
*giggling*
We've got a golden ticket, everybody. Okay.
So if I turn that on it'll do something? I think?
I have no idea. Alright.
We've got a way in... to go... the hell?
OH! I forgot you can peer through the goddamn keyholes, I forgot that was even a feature.
Okay. But it doesn't matter, because he's stuuuuck...
Which is good for us.
He-BIS-keh.
Op-a-dope.
Climb, please. Thank you.
Okay. So what we need to do, is we need to
number one, find the key for this,
which if I recall...
I'm gonna go ahead and get the magnet.
Let's see...
Boop.
Perfect.
Okay, so I need to go find the magnet,
because I need to be able to get the key.
Oh, I was right in front of it! Why couldn't I pick that up?
Because I'm dumb, that's why.
Alright.
So I can't assume that he's gonna be stuck forever.
What's over there? Nothin'.
So I gotta ta--I gotta take advantage of this immediately.
before things go horribly wrong for me,
which they always will.
Alright. So.
That doesn't work, does it?
Does it? Oh, it DOES work, well I don't need that.
Okay.
That was the advantage of turning the power on,
because that actually activated that thing.
So, now, I need to make THIS stupid-ass--why?
The doors in the, mortem, here.
I need to make THIS stupid-ass jump which I frickin' hate.
It's the worst jump in the game.
Yoop!
Okay, made it. Alright, good.
That wasn't so bad.
Okay, zhoop
Okay, so I got the keyyyy...
Uh-oh. There we go.
Wow. Can't believe I made that.
Alright, so we got that... get the key. Thank you. Alright, so then we take the key.
And then we can unlock this thing in here